[Music]
[Applause]
tell the people what's coming out
our new song sophia which
just for the record we did not come up
with after i played [ __ ] detroit
become human we actually
this idea came about immediately after
broke [ __ ] it was on the set of broke
[ __ ] hold on dude i'm just restarting
my camera real quick
oh yeah it's fine i'll just keep going
with this
we we um we were sitting on the set of
broke [ __ ]
and we were sitting with our producer
aiden and i was like
man what if we did like some crazy
because aiden was telling me
these weird meta music video concepts
and i was like
dude what if we did one and it was just
like ai robots for the video girls and
originally we were joking like cody and
i are joking like oh man like what if
their heads were just straight up like
[ __ ] ipads
and yeah oh yeah that was a little solar
panel like
no little segways with ipads on them
yeah yeah it's just like
just weird but uh you know
quickly you know i figured out vfx on
that would have been way too much money
so uh i knew that wait actually hold on
one second pause
real quick i think the original idea
wasn't the original one
to have all the video girls be like
super old
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that
was an idea yeah it was one where we
want to do like a tiger
type music video like around a pool yeah
but it's like us in like
10 or like 30 like 80 year olds but i
think someone had done that already
yeah so i was like ah so then yeah so
then yeah that's what kicked it off and
then i
was like okay what if they're all like
robots because it's just sort of like a
you know not so subtle commentary on
[ __ ]
everyone's obsession with sex robots and
stuff at the time so i knew about sophia
and i was like whoa that name is kind of
you know it's kind of a pretty ass name
so what if we just sort of you know
do a play on that so the whole track is
uh
uh double aunt andres
yes yeah yeah and also
i guess we won't say too much about the
video because when this comes out
if people are listening thursday night
then
you wouldn't have seen the video yet so
you should watch it tomorrow
and let us know what you think but i
think you gave like a general enough
idea
yeah that the video is yeah that um
man talk about a [ __ ] day
oh that was stressful right in the
middle of that [ __ ] i was like is this
gonna happen
oh yeah we will give it away but
this doesn't give anything away but in
the middle of it something just wasn't
clicking and you know what
nema is like super perfectionist right
so i have a skewed perception of what he
thinks is good
yeah and i just have to say this so when
he was bugging on that setup and he was
like it doesn't look good
and i'm looking at the monitor and i'm
like i see why you think it's not
perfect
but i think it's it's solid let's just
let's print it and let's move forward
so we hit it and we're losing time
and i could see he's really frustrated
so i step aside with him i'm like what's
up and he's like he's like i just it's
not that good man
he's like i feel like i'm [ __ ] up i'm
like bro no one's gonna judge you as
hard as
you're judging yourself right now and he
just he won't he can't let it go
so we come back we go to lunch and we
come back and then he kind of figures it
out
and then after he figures it out and
when i saw the difference i go oh
yeah yeah the other which setup was it
again
so it was when we said it's the one that
took for [ __ ] ever right
it was yeah and it was it's like the
main area
and where we see the main character of
the video
yeah and and it's
it was like in that and it just you know
it just does it just wasn't hitting and
then when he figured it out
that's what turned all the footage over
and and that's what gave us that crazy
ass look and we're like oh damn this is
[ __ ] fire
yeah yeah so um you know
shout out to nima and yeah shout out to
nemo because we know you're listening to
this
yeah by the way we [ __ ] know it and
you know we trashed them last episode
so i don't think we trash them we didn't
trash them no we didn't no we did but
you are a little [ __ ] boy yeah you are
a little punky you're a little punk ass
[ __ ] you're a little [ __ ] cry baby
[ __ ]
it doesn't look good it doesn't look
good it doesn't shut up
man i'm coming in a river dog
also thanks for thanks for shooting this
video yeah but also art isn't real bro
and like your whole career is a [ __ ]
farce so like stop complaining and be
happy with what you got
but like we love you though thank you
man thank you so much for your hard work
[Laughter]
this doesn't mean anything more like
more like uh
[ __ ] um
dow jones dp
more like doesn't
put out good material
[Music]
[ __ ] oh brother
oh brother this guy stinks more like
doesn't poop i haven't seen you take a
single [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah man
ever dude [ __ ] where's your butthole
dude do you even have a butthole
[ __ ] in front of me if it's real yeah
dude put that on a t-shirt [ __ ] in front
of me if it's real
[Laughter]
if it's real [ __ ] in front of me
dude the uh um
we we get in the way aesthetic
conversation and the bonus
oh yeah yeah right we probably should
talk about that no actually you can talk
about that now
just don't don't say what the prosthetic
is
oh yeah no i'm all i want to talk about
is
the material used to put that on your
body
i like how to [ __ ] rash after that
[ __ ] came
off oh yeah did you i don't know if you
were that way it was just like
sticky and yeah it's [ __ ] he was like
he's like you're gonna break out in that
area by the way if you don't clean it
off with alcohol or something and i was
like
what it's like 2 a.m i'm not gonna go
home and clean my neck with hydrogen
peroxide right now i'm gonna [ __ ] go
to bed
with the makeup on yeah that doesn't
look sus as hell coming in at 2am
rubbing [ __ ]
uh rubbing alcohol in your neck what are
you doing i mean
it was a it was a it was a set piece
it was a set prop
just on your neck yep just on my neck
just on my neck just right it's a hickey
god damn it i'll just it's a hickey i'm
sorry
[ __ ] hickey man i haven't no but we
can say this we can talk about the fact
that the
the piece that was built for the main
character
modeled around a certain part of the
body and we had someone that we can't
you know we did this song like
a year ago now yeah oh yeah yeah way
sooner yeah yeah yeah that's happened we
couldn't do a shoot for it
yeah yeah that's another thing i want to
make very clear before anyone starts
making comparisons about this that and
whatever
this [ __ ] was done in the can i'm gonna
get the exact date i'm gonna get the
exact date hold on
yes please do this came out i'm curious
this was forever ago
hold on hold on hold on hold on
it's way way back way way back way
way back bro you're not gonna [ __ ]
believe this [ __ ]
i bet can i guess the final
was complete yeah take a guess like
january yeah like the final
came to us february 21st
and like that was after changes and
stuff but like you know
i would say it was fairly minor so was
it nine months
because there there was a there was a
gap like we had done work on it
and then we left it hanging
and then we we picked it back up and we
finished it
and and yeah bro
the day we recorded was january 19.
oh no no january 26th [ __ ] hell
damn that's not great yeah that's just
me sitting for 10 months now that's
pretty wild man but i think that's
actually kind of normal
no it's normal it's very normal yeah so
people work on [ __ ] and
i mean people that do it and that's
that's their only thing that they go in
the studio every single day
yep like they build up a catalog of like
thousands of [ __ ]
songs and then they just yeah i think i
don't know i don't know i got made fun
of last time for
pretending to know about music so i'm
just not going to say [ __ ] about it
oh by who who said what some patreon
comment that was like dude it's so funny
hearing cody talk
about the industry it's like it's
literally like
we have been involved in it for the last
couple years i mean yeah
we're not speaking solely from our
experience bro yeah we brush a lot of
shelters man
yeah exactly we've heard a lot of
different things before they came out
yep so um you know this
neither here or there but uh no i think
it depends on the artist like i think a
guy like you know like
probably i would actually think less
people who are focused less on the
artistry i feel like they have more
tracks i feel like you know a guy like
tyler the creator i feel like he's got
a library of just like 32nd you know
10-second
ideas you know like oh a song with this
could be cool then it goes nowhere
whereas i feel you know
like a straight-up rapper like someone
like tory lanez
who just because he streams his he
streams
oh yeah we could talk about his album in
a second but before
back like back like a year and a half
ago or whatever when he was like
twitching all of his recording sessions
yeah and he'd literally go in and make
like four songs and freestyle every
single one of them and then just bank
them
and then leave come back the next they
do the same thing i mean like even it's
like when he wants to do it out what do
you
do down in the kitchen somewhere by my
wallet i think
uh oh yeah yeah yeah and so he's just
pumping out
i think when he wants to do an album
it's like besides this newest one it's
just like literally go to the hard drive
pick 12 tracks
and release them yeah i mean i think
you know even i mean even the story of
wiz khalifa when he made black and
yellow
he forgot what producer he was working
with
but i think he did that song and another
big song in the same night
and uh uh he's just sort of speaking of
the fact of like
you know oh yeah you you just gotta you
just gotta get it done you know and
and yeah i think it's that ability for
artists is crazy like
the the ones that have staying power i
feel like
those are the ones that just like can go
in and clock into 16. like even [ __ ]
black bear
when we send a short king's anthem that
[ __ ] came back in 24 hours like
there you go wild that was wild can we
wait can we just say this real quick
hold on
i don't want it you know i don't want to
toot our own horns or anything like that
[Music]
i don't want to to our horns too much
right
all right but i'm going to do a little
tooting right now okay
walkman almost 60 million on on spotify
that's [ __ ] ridiculous
short kings short king's about to hit 40
million that's what that's what
that's unreal
that is crazy i mean that's [ __ ]
crazy brookbridge is at 22.
that's what you were doing you remember
doing no sorry i this is [ __ ] so
shitty of me to do right now just going
through our own stats
dude wow we're killing it
but it's just weird to think that we
made remember we made no flex we were in
christian's apartment
yeah and we're piecing together the song
we made it you know whatever one
did you ever think that song would have
15 million streams
no i mean that's [ __ ] crazy yeah
honestly it is i mean when we made that
[ __ ] i'm like oh yeah
people will like this that like the
podcast
the same stay stable yeah almost has
nine which is insane
it's still man it's really cool it's
really uh just a blessing and an honor
yeah yeah to do this music with you and
i think that
um and i'm excited about this new song
and i'm pumped to see whatever comes
next you know
yeah it's a it's a man what a
what a trip bro just starting it as a
like
just because and then it just kind of
kept going
oh yeah it's just wild yeah
and um even just coming up with the
concept like executing it
and and just everything has been
wild it's crazy